vamos a hablar acerca de los grupos de
la tabla periódica una forma sencilla de
pensar en esto es comenzar con las
columnas la convención estándar es
enumerar las esta es la primera columna
así que este es el grupo 1 la segunda
columna es el grupo 2 el grupo 3 grupo 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 y 18 y
algunos de ustedes seguramente están
pensando qué pasa con estos elementos
del bloque efe que están aquí abajo si
dibujáramos la tabla periódica
apropiadamente estos estarían aquí y
tendríamos que desplazar todo esto desde
el bloque de y el bloque p hacia la
derecha para hacer espacio para los
elementos del bloque efe pero lo común
es que no los enumeramos lo interesante
de la tabla periódica y la razón por la
que nos tomamos el trabajo de llamar
grupos a estas columnas es porque la
mayor parte de los elementos en una
columna aunque hay muchas excepciones
tienen propiedades muy semejantes esto
es porque los elementos en una columna o
en un grupo tienden a tener el mismo
número de electrones en su capa a un
nivel energético más externo es decir
tienden a tener el mismo número de
electrones de valencia y estos
electrones de valencia o los electrones
en la capa más externa tienden a
coincidir aunque con leves variaciones
los electrones que tienden a reaccionar
son los que están en el nivel energético
más externo aunque hay varias e
interesantes excepciones a esto en los
metales de transición en el bloque de
pero ahora no entraremos en esos
detalles pensemos un poco en los grupos
que vamos a ver y por qué reaccionan de
forma similar veamos el grupo 1
aunque el hidrógeno es un elemento
aparte porque no trata de tener 8
electrones de valencia el hidrógeno en
la primera capa o nivel trata de tener
dos electrones de valencia como los
tiene el helio porque el hidrógeno no
tiene mucho en común con todos los demás
del grupo 1 si hacemos a un lado el
hidrógeno el grupo 1 es conocido como
los metales alcalinos y el hidrógeno no
se considera un metal alcalino
estos son los metales alcalinos
porque todos estos tienen propiedades
similares para responder a esto tenemos
que ver la configuración de los
electrones
por ejemplo la configuración de los
electrones del litio va a ser la misma
que la configuración de los electrones
del helio luego vemos que el segundo
nivel
2s uno tiene un electrón de valencia
tiene un electrón en su nivel más
externo y que hay del sodio el sodio va
a tener la misma configuración de
electrones que el neón y luego tiene 3s
uno nuevamente tiene un electrón de
valencia un electrón en su nivel más
externo así que todos estos elementos
anaranjados tienen un electrón de
valencia y tratan de alcanzar la regla
del octeto que es como un nirvana
estable para los átomos de manera que
pueden imaginar que son reactivos y
cuando reaccionan tienden a perder este
electrón en su nivel más externo y este
es el caso estos metales alcalinos son
muy reactivos y tienen propiedades muy
similares son brillantes y suaves y
debido a que son tan reactivos son
difíciles de encontrar sin que hayan
reaccionado con otros elementos sigamos
viendo los otros grupos
si vemos el que está inmediatamente a la
derecha a este grupo 2 de aquí se le
llama de metal es alcalino terreos y
nuevamente tienen muchas propiedades
similares porque tienen dos electrones
de valencia dos electrones en su nivel
más externo aunque no son tan reactivos
como los del grupo uno para ellos es más
fácil perder dos electrones que ganar
otros seis electrones para completar
ocho así que tienden a ser más o menos
reactivos y tienden a perder esos dos
electrones ahora algo interesante sucede
cuando llegamos al bloque de y
estudiamos esto cuando vimos la
configuración de los electrones pero si
vemos la configuración de electrones del
escandio vamos a escribirlo en magenta
la configuración electrónica de leds
cambio va a ser igual a la del argón y
el principio de sóftbol nos dice que en
la configuración de electrones tenemos 4
s 2 igual que el calcio pero en el mismo
principio de ausbanc nos dice que
tendremos un electrón en 3-d así que es
algo luego 3 de 14 s 2
ordenar bien los niveles permítanme
poner 3 de 1 antes que 4 s 2 y cuando
las personas piensan en el principio de
afa o se imaginan que todos los
elementos de este bloque de de alguna
manera llena en el sub nivel de ahora
como hemos visto en otros vídeos esto no
es del todo cierto pero cuando
conceptualizamos la configuración de
electrones puede ser útil luego llegamos
aquí y comenzamos a llenar el subnivel
pp así que por ejemplo si vemos la
configuración de electrones de digamos
el carbono el carbono va a tener la
misma configuración de electrones que el
helio y luego vamos a llenar el sub
nivel 2 s 2 y luego 2 p 2 así que dos p2
cuántos electrones de valencia tiene
bueno en su segundo nivel su nivel más
externo tiene 2 más 2 tiene 4 electrones
de valencia y esto se cumple para los
elementos de este grupo debido a esto el
carbono tiene una capacidad de formar
enlaces como el silicon y otros
elementos en este grupo y así podemos
continuar por ejemplo el oxígeno y el
azufre esto
quieren tomar dos electrones de algo más
porque ellos tienen seis electrones de
valencia y quieren tener ocho por lo que
forman enlaces de manera similar
tenemos este grupo amarillo de los
halógenos tiene un nombre especial son
los halógenos y estos son muy reactivos
porque tienen siete electrones de
valencia les encantaría tener un
electrón más de valencia por lo que les
encanta reaccionar especialmente con los
metales alcalinos de aquí y finalmente
llegamos aquí al nirvana atómico de los
gases nobles este es otro nombre para
este grupo 18 gases nobles y todos
tienen la propiedad de ser los reactivos
porque no reaccionan porque han llenado
su nivel más externo no tienen necesidad
son nobles están por encima de esa lucha
no tienen la necesidad de reaccionar con
nadie más